so in our first enigma video we left you
on a bit of a cliffhanger I was just
about to show you the floor in the
enigma machine
now that video was only meant to be a
short follow-up video but when we saw
the reaction to our first enigma video
we decided to come in and film again to
show you how that floor worked and how
they broke the enigma code now if you
want to see the original enigma video it
shows you how the enigma machine worked
go check that out we'll put the links in
the description but now let's have a
look at that flaw
so here's the Enigma machine again now
if I press the letter K there we go the
letter Q lights up this time now if I
keep pressing the letter K a different
letter lights up each time so a double
letter would not be a double letter in
the code so it's a very good code indeed
but it is never K itself so this was the
floor a letter never becomes itself so a
is not a B's not B and so on said it's
not Z this is a clue so the way you
break the enigma code is if you imagine
you have an enigma message you try and
guess a word or phrase that might appear
in that message now every morning six
o'clock in the morning the Germans would
send a weather report now that was a
standard form that was always the same
every day apart from the actual weather
it was always a standard format so we
can pick a word that's going to be in
that weather report we might pick the
word or phrase weather report or Vetta
bericht in German and I apologize now if
I've translated that badly my notes is
say select insured ago now I'm going to
write better bericht on a piece of paper
that's where the report there in German
here I've got an enigma code and I'm
going to slide my guess underneath the
code and I'm gonna try and find where
this phrase fits in the message now I
know a letter can't become itself so it
can't fit here because I have a t
becoming t so that's not where it fits
let's try this ten it can it fit here in
there I've got this T matching with T
again let's try here now I've got no
matching no matching from what I can see
no matching letters there so he might
fit there if I try that see look those
ours match shop so it can't fit there so
maybe it's here maybe this is the phrase
weather report now from this point we
can start breaking the Enigma code so
you could use different phrases try and
imagine what a German officer would send
in World War two so for example messages
would end with how Hitler
so is it Heil Hitler at the end of the
message now if it is we shouldn't have
any letters matching with Heil Hitler
hey cheese ease eyes what the British
codebreakers I'm showing had to do was
find a way to use this floor to break
enigma messages so he built a huge
machine called the bombe machine it was
designed by Alan Turing and another code
breaker called Gordon welchman it was a
big machine noisy thing it would rattle
around and this could help you break the
code in under 20 minutes so you would
have to break the code every morning so
every morning the settings for the
Enigma machine would change so all the
Enigma machines would change stroke of
midnight so that's why a machine that
could break the code that quickly was so
important so the bombe machine tried to
work out the plugboard
at the front of the Enigma machine if we
go back and the front of the Enigma
machine we have this thing called the
plugboard that connects letters into
pairs
you actually make ten pairs of letters
when I press a letter the signal first
goes through the plugboard
it then goes through the first rotor
through the second rotor through the
third rotor it then loops back then it
goes through the Machine again in
reverse order so then it goes through
the third rotor the second rotor the
first rotor and finally it goes through
the plugboard one more time and it
lights up one of these bulbs now I'm
going to try and draw that for you but
I'm going to make it as simple as I can
let's try and do that so first of all it
goes through the plug board and it goes
through all the rotors and I'm going to
call that just one big magic box called
our four rotors and the last thing it
does is it goes through the foot board
if we look at our weather report here
let's look in the second place T becomes
e let me do that
if I press T it goes through the
plugboard
through all the rotors through the plug
board again and out comes e now we're
going to use this to work out the plug
board I'm gonna make one guess I'm going
to guess T's connected to a on the plug
board that's a guess but I'm going to
use it so let's say
means that tea goes through the
footboard and out comes a now a goes
through the rotors now we know how the
rotors are wired up so we know that we
pick a position and find out what
happens to a that's not hard to do and I
don't know let's make something up let's
say it comes out as P but if I do that I
can deduce that P goes through the plug
board and becomes e which means I can
deduce that P is connected to e on the
plug board now that's pretty cool so
you've worked out one of the plug board
settings if that diagram works P must be
connected to e so I've done this a few
more times doing the same method using
my weather report crib and I've
discovered a few more plug board
settings so the first one we discovered
was PE now I've discovered K and Q are
connected on the footboard I've
discovered X and B are connected on the
plug board and I just covered TMG I'll
connect it on the plug board but this
last one is a problem I've discovered
that T and G are connected on the plug
board but I guessed that TN a were
connected on the footboard and it can't
be both this is called a contradiction
it can't be both T a and T G at the same
time this means my guess the TA was
wrong throw it away I got it wrong now
I'm going to check the next one
what TB I might check TC TD have to do
all 26 options
tae BTT T's ed if all the 26 options are
wrong that means your rotor position is
wrong
and what you do is you go click you
check the next rotor position and you go
through all that again
now that would take a very long time so
Alan Turing came up with two ways to
make this a bit quicker the first one a
really clever idea he noticed that once
you've found one mistake like ta + TG
this means that all these other
deductions are also wrong and they don't
need to be checked so they're all fruit
of a poison tree they can all be
rejected at the same time
and you don't need to check them again
so that really speeds it up the other
way to speed it up is you can do this
instantaneously with electrical circuits
so that's what the bombe machine did it
has applied an electrical current to my
assumption ta the electrical current
flows through the Machine it flows
through TG which means long but it would
also flow through all these other
deductions which means I can find all my
deductions which are all wrong and I can
do it instantaneously with electrical
circuits and then it will go connect and
check the next and it could go through
all the rotor positions in about 20
minutes so the main thing to remember is
the bombe machine is built a little bit
backwards it's a process of elimination
also what you're left with is what
wasn't wrong and you would actually
check that by hand and see if it works
the bombe machine was named in honor of
a Polish code breaking machine called
bomba bomba
was a completely different machine
worked on a completely different
principle it wasn't a huge machine you
could sit it on your desk if you wanted
to and it exploited a floor in the
German procedures now they could use
bomba the polis could use bomba to break
army and air force Enigma codes but they
couldn't break naval Enigma codes so
what Alan Turing had to do was find a
way to break Army Air Force and Navy
Enigma codes and it had to be a bit more
robust so that if the Germans choose to
change their procedures that this method
would still work what the Navy was was
doing differently is the rotor starting
positions were actually sent at the
beginning of each message but they were
sent in another code entirely so it was
a completely different code just to send
the rotor starting positions so you need
to work out how that worked as well
before he could even start breaking the
naval code is there anything that the
makers of the Enigma machine could have
done to have avoided this problem was
this some simple thing that the Enigma
makers could have put into that device
there and it would have
being broken like this well hindsight is
a fabulous thing you wouldn't you wanted
to make it so that a letter could become
itself that was the flaw and so the
British saw in Ziggler they said that's
a good idea
we'll have that they nicked the idea we
saw in nygma and we decided to make one
of our own we called it the type X
machine except we took out the floor so
a letter could sometimes become itself
this made it a more secure machine now
from what I've heard the Germans tried
to break our code but they concluded
that it was better than the Enigma
machine so they they gave up trying at
least that's what I've heard it's very
difficult to know for sure it was all
very secret so if you've watched our
original video about how the code
machine works and this one and you still
want more I've got a third video with
all the extra material and offcuts which
isn't listed but you can find the links
here on the screen and in the video
description below if it's of brown paper
used in these videos can also be found
on our eBay site for people who like to
get their hands on them and if you've
watched all the Enigma videos and all
the numberphile videos and you still
want more can I recommend my chemistry
channel periodic videos because recently
we got our hands on a super high-speed
camera and filmed a bunch of reactions
so we can show them an ultra slow motion
the videos are really cool and there's
loads more to come go and have a look if
it sounds like something you might like
all the links are below in the video
description and here on the screen and
as usual thanks so much for watching
talk to you again so